like way for the Lord Chancellor
hi I David Michael Gork do solemnly
sincerely and truly declare and affirm
do you solemnly and sincerely and truly
declare and affirm that I will be
faithful and bear true allegiance I will
be faithful and bear true allegiance to
Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth a second to
Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth the second
heirs and successors heirs and
successors according to law according to
law I I David Michael Gork do solemnly
sincerely and truly declare and affirm
do solemnly sincerely and truly declare
and affirm
you saw me sincerely and truly declare
and affirm that I will well and truly
serve that I will well and truly serve
our sovereign lady queen elizabeth ii
our sovereign lady queen elizabeth ii in
the office of Lord High Chancellor Great
Britain in the office of Lord High
Chancellor of Great Britain I I David
Michael Gork do solemnly sincerely and
truly do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm declare and affirm
that in the office of Lord High
Chancellor of Great Britain in the
office of Lord Chancellor I will respect
the rule of law I will respect the rule
of law defend the independence of the
judiciary defend the independence of the
judiciary and discharge my duty and
discharge my duty to ensure the
provision of resources to ensure the
provision of resources the efficient and
effective support for the efficient and
effective support of the course for
which I am responsible of the courts for
which I am responsible and your
Chancellor would you sign the three
affirmations and the book in front of
you
My Lord Chancellor it is my great
pleasure to welcome you here today on
behalf of Her Majesty's judges and to
receive your affirmations on taking
office as Lord High Chancellor of Great
Britain
it is an historic office a great office
of state and an office of single
constitutional importance we are
particularly delighted to welcome your
mother Susan wife Rachel and sons
William Robert and Henry to share in our
pleasure at witnessing the beginnings of
the next step in your most distinguished
career the offices of law Chancellor and
Lord keeper of the Great Seal are
ancient
but this ceremony is a recent
development that reflects the
constitutional evolution of the office
in recent times we greet you in our full
ceremonial robes not that often worn
perhaps a little overdressed facade but
the solemnity of this occasion is
designed to reflect the most important
position that the office of Lord
Chancellor occupies in our
constitutional settlement that
importance is reflected in the statutory
oaths which we have just heard all
ministers are required by the
constitutional reform act to uphold the
Independence of the judiciary but you My
Lord Chancellor have a special duty to
defend that independence as well as to
respect the rule of law and ensure the
necessary resources for the courts and
tribunals for which you are responsible
your appointment had many lawyers and
legal historians dusting down their
copies of Lord Campbell's great work the
lives of the Lord Chancellor's he was of
course Lord Chancellor himself and I
might add before that Lord Chief Justice
his work on the lives of the chief
justices alas attracts rather less
attention with
or Campbell's work is consulted because
parallels may be found between any new
Lord Chancellor and one or more of his
or her predecessors my Lord Chancellor
you are an East Anglian man indeed a nip
switch man and was there educated at
Northgate
high school you are not of course the
First Lord Chancellor from Ipswich one
of that town's most famous sons was
Thomas Wolsey Cardinal Archbishop of
York and Lord Chancellor to Henry the
eighth sadly the emoluments of your
office will not enable you to live in
the style to which he became accustomed
to build palaces or endow schools and
colleges from Ipswich he went to some
Dedmon Hall Oxford to study law you
determined on a career in the law and
qualified as a solicitor training with
Richard's Butler and then practising in
corporate law with McFarland's from 1997
to 2005 but the lure of politics was
strong in 2005 you were elected as
Member of Parliament for Southwest
hartfordshire
a seat you have held at each of the
subsequent general elections you served
on both the procedure Select Committee
and the Treasury select committee before
being appointed a shadow Treasury
Minister in 2007 that experience My Lord
Chancellor propelled you to the Treasury
following the general election in 2010
you were appointed Exchequer secretary
an office you held until 2014 you then
became financial secretary in 2014
before entering the cabinet as chief
secretary to the Treasury in 2016 you
slipped free of the Treasury last year
when you were appointed as Secretary of
State for Work and Pensions one question
which excited the legal turret at
Twitter what grotty 10 days ago when
your appointment was announced was
whether you are the first solicitor to
be launched on
slur one suggestion that was mooted was
that sir Thomas Moore had started life
as a solicitor that caused collective
apoplexy in Lincoln's Inn not appear to
have been the case a more hopeful
possibility was Edward lord thurlow he
was Lord Chancellor for 14 years between
1778 and 1792 under four different prime
ministers he certainly did articles with
a solicitor at the time that was a
common feature of the training of
barristers but I believe that he did not
qualify as a solicitor in the 19th
century another possibility was Edward
Sugden Lord st. Leonard's he was Lord
Chancellor for a brief 10 months in 1852
much ahead of his time in serving four
months
he began his career working as a
solicitor's clerk but he too did not
qualify and was instead called to the
bar that more promising still was thomas
wylde law true in 1805 he was admitted
as an attorney that was undoubtedly the
equivalent of a solicitor at that side
of the profession was divided between
solicitors and attorneys solicitors
practicing in the equity courts and
attorneys practicing in the common law
courts that distinction was swept away
in the 1870s along with many other
cobwebs surrounding the legal profession
and our courts and the single profession
of solicitor emerged but by Lord
Chancellor I readily recognize that
entering an equivalent profession is not
the same as qualifying as a solicitor so
with some confidence but subject to
contradiction from the president of the
Law Society or a thousand tweets before
we leave word we can take it that you
are indeed the first solicitor to have
achieved the great office of Lord
Chancellor that is a distinct
achievement of which both you and the
profession can be justly proud your
legal experience as a solicitor will
bring fresh insight and a new
perspective as you discharge the
obligations and responsibilities of your
office your work as a solicitor will
also have left you with a clear
understanding of the central importance
of well functioning and properly funded
courts and tribunals and of a vigorous
legal profession in securing the rule of
law and access to justice both of which
underpin social and economic growth and
stability as we prepare to leave the
European Union we must ensure that
appropriate legal instruments are in
place to provide necessary continuity
and to support our courts in legal
profession in their preeminent position
in international and commercial dispute
resolution
you will also understand the importance
of promoting English law as the law of
choice for contracts worldwide and the
flexibility that the common law offers
in a fast developing world one question
which few people seem to have asked is
whether you are the first Secretary of
State for Work and Pensions or
equivalent to have been appointed Lord
Chancellor I think not in October 1944
Sir William Jewett was appointed
minister of national insurance at the
head of the then newly formed Ministry
of National Insurance in the wartime
coalition government the Department of
Work and Pensions is the lineal
descendant of that ministry
Sir William remained there for only
seven months that has a familiar ring
but following the general election in
1945 he was appointed Lord Chancellor by
Clement Attlee at you to my Lord
Chancellor served for seven months at
the head of the Department of Work and
Pensions and you too have been appointed
Lord Chancellor Lord Jarrett as he
became remains Lord Chancellor until the
next general election in 1951 a period
of six years might I be allowed to
whisper that stability in office of that
sort has its advantages we now have
fixed term Parliament's subject of
course to events and the next is
scheduled for 2022 we look forward in
the years ahead to developing a strong
productive and harmonious working
relationship with you my Lord Chancellor
on behalf of the judiciary I
congratulate you and welcome you warmly
to your office
mr. attorney I'd like to thank the Lord
Chief Justice for that warm welcome and
I look forward to working with you and
other members of the bench I'd also like
to start by thanking my predecessor and
cabinet colleague David Livington well I
think quickly established himself as an
effective Lord Chancellor and Secretary
of State I very much hope to emulate his
speedy grasp of such an important
constitutional role being appointed as
Lord Chancellor is a huge honor and
deeply humbling dare I say it was also a
little daunting especially when he
looked back at some of the previous
custodians of this historic title over
the centuries in light of such an
illustrious roll call of historical
figures I think it was any natural for a
new incumbent to look for a familiar
reference point as the mall Chief
Justice has reminded us a former Lord
Chancellor from my hometown of Ipswich
was neither none other than Cardinal
Wolsey an auspicious connection given he
went on to serve as mall Chancellor for
14 years my enthusiasm was however a
little tempered when I recalled how
walls his time as Lord Chancellor was
made fraught through dealing with Henry
stripped of his title and his wealth and
faced charges of treason
after an unsuccessful attempt to
negotiate a settlement with a powerful
European supranational
organisation thankfully not all the duty
is exercised by Cardinal Wolsey
continued to fall on the shoulders of
the Lord Chancellor so let me turn to
the specific responsibilities I have
affirmed to uphold today defending the
independence of the judiciary and
respecting the rule of law that is the
foundation of our democracy our way of
life and the safeguard of fairness and
freedom in our society the pomp and
pageantry may be centuries old but what
they represent forged from nine hundred
years of history remain relevant and
important today you the judiciary are a
part of the rule of law you are hold and
exercise that every day in the judgments
and decisions you make and it being
called upon to make decisions on some of
the most difficult moral and technical
issues of our time it is a job that
requires expertise and deep knowledge
but your task also requires independence
from the other branches of the state you
must be free to make decisions without
fear or favor and without undue
influence that's why I take seriously
the solemn affirmation I have made today
to defend the independence and to
respect the rule of law this commitment
also includes ensuring efficient and
effective support for courts I want
people to have confidence in every part
of their justice system that means
crimes being properly investigated it
means effective prosecution's where
there is sufficient evidence and it is
in the public interest
it means courts handing down sentences
that fit the crime it also means a
justice system supports victims and
ensures a smooth and efficient process
for litigants for example through new
technology and greater innovation
I look forward to working closely with
the Lord Chief Justice and senior
judiciary to build on the important work
that is already underway to reform and
modernize our courts and tribunals
system and to make this a reality
whether in criminal or civil the UK's
legal system is respected around the
world something that I have seen for
myself having worked in corporate law as
a trainee solicitor over 20 years ago I
was struck working on a shipping
litigation case was an English tribunal
applying English law that was
determining a dispute involving cargo
being shipped across the Pacific on a
Greek own ship
greet and ship with if I recall
correctly an Indonesian crew the only
apparent connection to the UK was that
the contracts were under English law and
determined by English tribunals that was
the case then it's the case now and it
will continue to be the case after we
leave the European music because the UK
leads the way in global legal services
English law and UK courts provide the
certainty clarity and flexibility that
clients from around the world want I
know just how important this sector is
not just for London but for cities and
regions across the United Kingdom that's
why I want an outcome from our
negotiations with the European Union
that is good for our legal system a good
for our position as a provider of legal
services around the world one that
protects and promotes a strong and
successful legal services sector that
means ensuring close and comprehensive
arrangements for civil judicial
cooperation with the EU after brexit it
means a legal services sector that
benefits from and serves as a catalyst
for future trade I want to see London
continue to be an international hub for
finance and legal services but also
legal services continuing to grow and
thrive in regional centres serving as
specialist hubs I look forward to
working with the legal services sector
and the judiciary to build on our legal
services a great campaign
last year to promote the UK's legal
services on the world stage the
reputation of our legal services is
underpinned by our world-leading
judiciary respected for its expertise
and its independence as Lord Chancellor
and a call to working with you Lord
Chief Justice and other senior members
of the judiciary to ensure we continue
to attract exceptional and talented
people in order for it to remain strong
free from improper influence and truly
independent indeed to remain the envy of
the world
now I mentioned cobbler Wolseley managed
14 years as Lord Chancellor for seven
years at the Treasury seven months at
DWP and having just completed my first
seven days at the Ministry of Justice
that may be an ambitious record to match
although I have read on Twitter and
elsewhere that I have set a record of my
own being the first solicitor to be
appointed Lord Chancellor as indeed you
mentioned or chief justice I'm pleased
that so far at least this record remains
intact even after such careful and
scrupulous deliberation from you for
chief justice they do say that the law
is an iterative process so I await to be
revised but what I can say to you today
is that during my time as Lord
Chancellor I will be ambitious for our
country's legal services I will be
steadfast in my commitment to defend the
independence of the judiciary and
respect the rule of law and I will be
determined in our work to create a
justice system that is open to all a
justice system that everyone in the
country can have confidence in a one
that lives up to the deep-rooted sense
of justice and fairness the United
Kingdom is known for around the world
Thank You mr. Attorney my lord this
ceremony highlights the advantages in
background and in training that a new
Lord Chancellor brings to the role in
the case of this Lord Chancellor many
have been mentioned already but not I
think all true it is that he
is a lawyer which there were novelty in
the recent history of the role could
nonetheless have its advantages of much
greater significance however I suggest
is David's experience in the Treasury
and not just for the obvious reasons
knowing how the Treasury approved
spending or more often don't will be a
real advantage in the next spending
round in which he will participate on
behalf of the justice system it may also
assist in his most important
responsibilities of which I know he is
acutely aware to defend the independence
of the judiciary and uphold the rule of
law and to do so with it government is
not always an easy task it occasionally
involves telling political colleagues
they cannot do as they wish
luckily however telling fellow ministers
they can't have what they want is the
daily business of the chief secretary to
the Treasury great distinction crucially
of course the Lord Chancellor has
responsibility for the prison system and
in this the current Lord Chancellor has
an unusual advantage I suspect he is the
only Lord Chancellor in modern times at
least to have spent the night in a Cell
and lest anyone get the wrong idea
it was only to raise money for a local
hospice in his constituency but I have
no doubt the experience will nonetheless
be valuable my Lord David and I were
elected to Parliament on the same day
and over the last 12 years we've spent
in Parliament together I've been able to
observe his impressive intellect his
sound judgment and his application to
the roles in which he has served my Lord
they are qualities from which we shall
all benefit during his tenure as Lord
Chancellor and I welcome him warmly to
the role mr. chairman
my lord it is an honor and a privilege
for me on behalf of the bar of England
and Wales to join your lordship and mr.
return in welcoming the new Lord
Chancellor this morning it's an honor
that's been conferred on all recent
chairs of the bar but that in no way
diminishes the significance and
importance of the role of the Lord
Chancellor no one at the bar milord is
in any doubt that it here instalove law
has been critical in our largely written
constitution or that this remains as
important as ever it is what has enabled
us to build a stable and prosperous
society it has been a counterbalance to
the supremacy of Parliament and
historical prerogatives ensuring that
they are not misused and keeping the
power of the state over our citizens and
others within proper bounds it is also
indoor insured due process and
observance by the executive of the
proper limits of the powers granted by
Parliament and as your lordship has said
as it secured the strength and the
independence of our judiciary under your
leadership
it is our adherence to the rule of law
both practically and philosophically and
both in the United Kingdom and overseas
through that we have set an example to
the world in too many nations the rule
of law remains an aspiration and not a
reality in too many nations the rule of
law is under threat and their example
the Lord reminds us of what society
might look like without the rule of law
it shows us what we have to lose and why
we must never take it for granted it
shows us to its potential fragility if
it is not constantly recognized applied
and reinforced that recognition
application and reinforcement needs to
take place not just in our courts but
also in Parliament and in government and
in our common
discourse and it must extend not just to
the rule of law itself but also to the
independence of the judiciary and to
access to justice in the courts over
which our judges preside it falls to the
Lord Chancellor to be their champion and
their defender around the cabinet table
in the chambers and corridors in
Westminster in the public domain and on
the international stage their nature is
such that their defense requires more of
a Lord Chancellor in more difficult
times and while all these are onerous
duties and heavy responsibilities of a
different order from those born by
secretaries of state and their
performance depends on the experience
abilities and character of the holder of
the office of Lord Chancellor comforted
by the Lord Chancellor's words this
morning we are confident that in the
person of mr. Gork we have a Lord
Chancellor with the understanding and
the personal qualities that the role
demands and who brings with him the
invaluable experience mr. eternia's any
years and treasury that should stand him
in good stead in securing the resources
that justice requires her in our nation
the bar of England Wales looks forward I
look forward to working with our new
Lord Chancellor to assist him in
performing those duties and
responsibilities and in carrying a
message to the world about our
undiminished strengths in law and
justice we wish him well
and a long and successful 10
my lord as president of the Law Society
of England and Wales on behalf of the
society under solicitous profession I'm
delighted that Her Majesty has seen fit
to appoint you as Lord Chancellor given
that the office goes back at least to
Norman times it has taken a very long
time for a member of our profession to
occupy this role as Lord Chancellor you
are the highest ranking of all the great
officers of state save only for the Lord
High Steward however despite what the
government claims are historically high
employment figures that position has
remained vacant for several centuries so
you know you are basically now the main
man we are very proud and delighted that
our solicitor now holds such high legal
and political office and I in no way
seek to contradict the Lord Chief
Justice you are indeed the first
solicitor ever appointed to this role
following confirmation of your
appointment you quickly stated via
Twitter that justice is the cornerstone
of our democracy and a key part of a
fairer society and that you would
continue driving the work of your
predecessors the duties of a Lord
Chancellor go beyond those of a
Secretary of State they go beyond
responsibilities to the cabinet or to
the department because they included
duty to serve the interests of justice
to protect the rule of law and the
Independence of the judiciary it goes
without saying that our profession like
others is faced with unprecedented
structural economic and regulatory
challenges as the country withdraws from
the European Union but together with
colleagues from the judiciary and the
bar the Law Society is here to support
the government in addressing these
challenges our expertise our knowledge
and our resources are
your disposal we are ready willing and
able to assist you to ensure the the
economic contribution of the legal
services sector is uncompromised and the
integrity of our system of justice is
retained as his lordship per said he
practiced in the city firm McFarland's
were you focused exclusively on
financial services regulation the
current senior partner Charles Martin
tells us we are certain that his sound
and extensive knowledge of the law and
the legal world will equip him to deal
with important aspects in his role as
Lord Chancellor and besides the
extensive knowledge of financial
services and tax law you have other
interests which help you to keep your
feet firmly on the ground and close to
your constituents in South West Hartford
sure you are rumored to be an avid
cricket fan as well as a lifelong
supporter of Ipswich Town FC detractor
Boys a state of affairs on which is a
fellow of supporter of a championship
team you have my utmost sympathy
it is perhaps worth noting that in Mick
McCarthy you have the longest-serving
manager in the championship and in
passing I noticed that you did what we
couldn't do and you beat Leeds last
Saturday indeed as we speak the tractor
boys will be preparing to travel up to
the northwest were on Saturday they will
be playing another great team fallen on
hard times and I appreciate that getting
up to speed with the new job will be
all-consuming but should you be able to
ease away from the duties of state then
I would be delighted to buy you a pint
of the finest northern bitter at
halftime and I think I can say with some
confidence that for you it will not be
anything like the nine nil defeat you
witnessed at the hands of another
northwestern side in 1994 which I
understand still stands as a premier
league record I'm told that the
was successful Lord Chancellor we
welcome you to this great office of
state and look forward to working with
you in delivering our shirt aims of
upholding the rule of law and supporting
access to justice for all our citizens
we very much hope that unlike some of
your predecessors you will emulate the
manager of the tractor Boys and enjoy a
lengthy and successful tenure in the
post my lord
I move that these proceedings be
recorded in the books of the Queen's
remembrance so be it